good morning believe nation today's
message is make product over to you Vin
Diesel my advice to people who want to
pursue their dream is to find any way
that they can to make product my
philosophy is that product is the most
important thing I started acting when I
was 7 years old and I didn't get paid as
an actor until I did Saving Private Ryan
and I was 30 at that time so there was
many many years of unemployment
obviously what I learned later was that
I had to have something I had to have
product regardless of how big or small
it was and the first thing that I did
was direct a short film called multi
facial so what do you think I think Vin
Diesel isn't telling us to necessarily
go to and manufacture create products
when he says make products he's telling
us to go promote ourselves build a brand
and to go and network instead of waiting
for the next deal to happen I can relate
this to the first few months of my own
practice when I didn't have a lot of
real estate deals and I went out and
talked with real estate agents and
mortgage brokers chocolate friends
family and created social media accounts
to do all of these things I think when
your site in the business you thinking
is gonna be easier than it is if you
think it's gonna be hard but you don't
think it's gonna be that hard to start
you quickly tap out your network like
I'm sure when you started your business
you talked to friends and family and
then you realize how quickly that runs
dry and you don't have enough business
and that's when the oh crap moment hits
you that I gotta go do something more
and that's scary and a lot of people
don't want to do it and a lot of people
do just sit and wait hoping for some
deal to happen
never does and so you need to be out
there doing stuff you need to be able to
promoting yourself and talking to people
and networking and do you whether you
want to do YouTube videos or you're
better at doing speeches or you're
better at one-on-one meetings or you're
better at setting up partnerships
whatever it is you're out there hustling
while you wait right you're waiting for
the big deal to happen until then you're
not just waiting on it you're hustling
to try to get more deals to happen
you're waiting on somebody to get back
to you great you're hustling to try to
get more deals to happen as well
and that that has to be your life as an
entrepreneur if you're just waiting on
something else to happen your business
is not going to take off so the question
today today is how do you have so while
you wait how do you hustle while you
wait leave it in the comments below we
will join the discussion thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso so what do you think means
you have to do it you can't you can't
pull out of it